le chiffre est astronomique plus de 900
millions de mètres cubes d'eau potable
sont perdus chaque année en France soit
l'équivalent de la consommation annuelle
de 18 millions d'habitants un constat
inadmissible alors que la ressource en
eau va se faire de plus en plus rare 170
communes françaises dans lesquelles un
litre sur deux n'arrive pas jusqu'au
compteur vont donc être accompagnés
financièrement par l'État pour faire des
travaux en Loir-et-Cher un village est
concerné et veillant au nord de
Romorantin plus d'explications avec
Florent Clavel
veillant 160 habitants 25 km de
canalisation et un taux de fuite peu
enviable un litre d'eau potable sur deux
pompé dans cette station n'arriverait
pas jusqu'au robinet des habitants
de surpression c'est à dire que c'est là
où on envoie l'eau chez les habitants la
petite commune du Loir-et-Cher mauvais
élève de la région le maire s'enterroge
d'humidité c'est un peu difficile
d'investir 250 000 euros et derrière
quand vous dise voilà vous êtes mauvais
moi ça ça me reste un peu en travers de
la gorge
car en croire le maire le réseau d'eau
potable de veillant n'a jamais été
laissé à l'abandon au contraire à
l'image de cette station de traitement
2014 voilà donc c'est récent c'est
récent ça
alors comment expliquer que la commune
fasse malgré tout partie des 170 points
noirs du plan o pour l'élu la vérité est
toute bête le gouvernement s'est appuyé
sur des chiffres obsolètes ceux de 2019
qui n'ont rien à voir avec ceux
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on est plutôt
bien puisqu'on est à 85 90% de rendement
voilà
normal au lieu de au lieu de 50 à peine
50% 46%. voilà donc c'était quoi le
problème en fait j'en sais rien
j'ai aucune idée je sais pas pourquoi
cette année là il y a eu voilà peut-être
eu des erreurs de comptage il y a
peut-être eu j'en sais rien j'ai aucune
idée mais le maire l'a déjà assuré à la
sous-préfète le chèque promis par le
gouvernement 180 millions d'euros à
l'échelle de l'Hexagone il le prendra
bien l'argent servira à rembourser les
90 compteurs d'eau qu'il a fait
installer récemment sur la commune
précisément
pour qu'il n'y ait plus d'erreur